in new york city right now well in
cities around the country but especially
new york
crime is going through the roof
grime is going through the roof there's
a horrible story of a man
who just attacked some poor thai woman
on the subway platform this man had 44
previous arrests but he was walking
around free now according to the left
the way to expand freedom is to let the
criminals out of jail and not to arrest
them in the first place
actually i think it would expand the
freedom of this thai woman and every
ordinary citizen of new york
if you threw the criminals in prison
restrict
that freedom right restrict that license
you're going to expand freedom for all
of the citizens
this man
it's a hard video to watch
there's a man who just approaches this
woman on the platform and just beats the
living hell out of her a man he is in
queens
he's got 44 arrests in his life
charged on thursday for the brutal
mugging in november of this thai woman
which took place in manhattan so it's in
the supposedly the safest borough of new
york
the guy grabbed this woman from behind
dragged her then threw her to the ground
punched her in the face four times then
made off with her purse oh he sexually
assaulted her too by the way
this
animal this attacker
should be put away from society
he's an a he's a beast he's an animal he
shouldn't be allowed in free polite
society
i believe in second chances i really do
i think people even who commit really
terrible crimes i believe in second
chances i sometimes even believe in
third chances
what i do not believe in is 45th chances
i think 45th chances is a little bit too
far
and by the way obviously it would have
been much better for this woman that he
just brutalized if this animal had been
put in prison and not allowed out
obviously it would be better for the
people of new york who now they have to
fear for their lives every time they get
on a subway
even in manhattan which is the safe
borough
but it would be better for him too
i don't think he's living a particularly
flourishing life
mugging women and engaging in more and
more crime and vice and sin and living
like a filthy disgusting animal
giving away his humanity throwing it
away so that he can take some woman's
dignity and take her purse and run away
and go do it to someone else
i don't think that's good for him i
think it would be much better for him
if he were locked up
being punished being rehabilitated doing
a little introspection maybe and perhaps
even repenting and perhaps even turning
his life around he's not going to do
that on the streets
the only way he's going to do that isn't
is in prison
and and the left won't do it
because and what it really comes down to
is their perverted conception of freedom
i think they really believe like like
rashida talib says you got to abolish
the prisons the reason why we have
oppression in america is because we we
lock up these animals
people who who mug women and sexually
assault them 44 45 times and then
because we lock those people up
that's why we don't have freedom in
america no it's the opposite of course
it's the opposite if you've been
listening to this show for a while you
have certainly heard me talk about my
helix mattress i love my helix mattress
it is absolutely magnificent mattress
built just for you it's so beautiful
well helix has left the bedroom and now
moved into the family room the living
room they've started making sofas they
just launched a new company called all
form they're already making the greatest
sofas we have ever seen
so what makes an all-form sofa really
really great for starters it is the
easiest way that you can customize a
sofa using premium materials and at a
fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you can pick your fabric the sofa
color the color of the legs sofa size
and shape to make sure
that it is absolutely perfect for you
and your home they've got arm chairs and
love seats all the way up to an eight
seat sectional so there's something for
everyone you can always start small and
buy more seats later on if you want your
all-form sofa to grow and change with
you when you move as your family changes
it's really really top-notch stuff i
love it if you think it sounds a little
risky don't worry you get 100 days to
decide if you want to keep it that is
more than three months if you don't love
it they'll pick it up for free give you
a full refund but you're gonna love it
they've got a forever warranty a forever
warranty but you're gonna love it find
your perfect sofa check out allforum.com
knowles all form is offering twenty
percent off all orders for our listeners
that's all form dot com slash knowles
i'm glad you like that clip ring the
bell please
you will get the notifications if you
don't get the notifications subscribe
over at apple podcast spot if i stitch
your google play wherever you get your
audio podcasts type in
the michael null show subscribe leave a
five star review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]